hey you are you wasting your time on
social media again your brothers and
sisters in the slum net from Norway are
establishing a Masjid a dawa Center
establishing a Masjid to convey The
Message of Islam is one of the best
Deeds a Muslim can do there's a huge
need for it in Norway you know this and
I know this so that makes the Lord even
greater so give generously and Allah
azzawajal give you
oh
[Music]
assalamu alaikum
how are you guys
doing we have another individual in the
Scandinavian region this time of Arab
origin who has burned the Quran and this
is becoming a trend and I was in two
minds should I actually make a video
about this individual or not
then I thought why not because actually
some good can come from it
this individual to me is as
insubstantive
as a ghost in fact his existence to me
is as good as his non-existence I mean
whether he's over the ground or under
the ground to me is the same
but this individual has come out and
tried to burn the Quran and insert bacon
into it and try and antagonize the
Muslim Community probably to expedite
his immigration case that he's got in
Sweden and then he groveling on his
hands and knees effectively went to make
a video asking the Swedish government to
give him protection and criticizing them
for one thing or another I want to let
the Muslim Community know the following
we've actually been really using these
people yes we have we've been using
people like this Quran burner and the
other Quran burner and the third Quran
burner to build I would say some of the
the best infrastructure in Scandinavia
and in that for example as you guys will
know from the advertisements on this
channel has been we've actually been
able to build so far the biggest
infrastructure in Scandinavia yes and
wallahi I tell you this as a measure of
explaining the Glo giving you glad
tidings as the Muslim communities a big
chunk of that a big reason for that
actually has been
because of the anger that the Muslim
Community has felt towards people like
this and sometimes we as the Muslim
Community need to get angry to get mad
to get triggered why so that we can
respond in kind and this is something
you will claim to Josiah he mentioned in
one of his books as she felt Ali in fact
he says that sometimes the devil or the
enemy of Islam or something which is
negative can arouse us and give us the
religious impetus to respond and to
awaken something which would otherwise
be dormant within our very psyches and
so I think we have to think of it from
this perspective this is positive it's
always been positive when you have a
negative Force which we then respond to
which we have an opportunity to do so
here again the link is in the
description in this this is the biggest
Scandinavian dawa Center and we went to
uh I went to it myself I saw that they
have tangibly and physically expanded
its premises they are printing materials
they have qurans there that they're
going to in the Scandinavian languages
they're expanding all over this
udawa in Sweden and this is the best for
me tangible response we haven't just
been all mouth here we haven't just been
speaking because someone will say well
what condemning is not really getting us
anywhere we're doing something as the
Muslim Community in Europe which
actually affects
Muslims and non-muslims in that region
itself and they're helping us they are
mascots we're using them like tools
we're using them like a mobile phone let
me be even more crude and crass they use
we're using them sorry to say like a
prostitute and I'm not saying that this
is a legitimate profession but these
people are mascots for us they're the
antagonists in the story they are an
important part
of the fundraising experience and of
course you as the Muslim person and me
as a Muslim person now have the have the
ability to click the link below and
donate to the biggest dollar Center in
all of Scandinavia that's all I have to
say about this nobody was
the prophet Muhammad
told us whoever builds a mosque for
Allah Allah will build for him a similar
house in Jannah
and we know the great reward that will
not only be gained but rather will fill
your grave after your death whenever
someone prays there whenever someone
gives shahada in the Masjid whenever
someone learns something in the Masjid
yes that will be something that you'll
have on your scale